john there is a disturbing
thing happening with teenagers and with
covid that you've been talking about on
your show and james our producer sent us
a
uh an article on the loneliness issue
and teen mental health with this
that is it's scary yeah if you
if you could construct a way to torture
teenagers
it would be to isolate them put them in
a house
with their family for a year or more
and force them to connect via social
media
which are outlets that we know
exacerbate anxiety and depression these
things
make people feel less than make people
just accelerate this disconnection man
and
it's it's an absolute mess dave it's a
mess
so the kids not being back in the
classroom is
is causing uh uh well i mean we're
seeing suicides increase we're seeing
loneliness increase we're seeing
just uh because the development human
development requires interaction
with other humans and it's not and
social media is not interaction
no and especially especially with kids
especially
with with teenagers in middle school we
they are figuring out who they are
in relationship with other people and
when you take that off it is just like
cutting the string on a balloon and it's
off right
there's just no way to ground when it's
just you and a screen
and then you just you go through these
curated images of
what other people are supposedly doing
what their lives are supposedly like and
it makes you feel less than and more
isolated more isolated more isolated
well
and then people have digital courage and
so they become bullies
and mean and other stuff here's another
interesting thing when you and i were
kids
and we ran into a real bully or we are
one ourselves and we
somebody mouthed off to us that hurt
and then we went about our day and with
our friends and
there's just a natural cycle to that
when it's in black and white text
it stays you read over and over and you
go back to it you go back to it and it
re-injures and re-injures that's another
thing
if you lose lost a grandparent from uh
so you've got a generation that wasn't
connected enough
with humans as it was but on top of that
you just took them completely and stuck
them in a house that's right
with covid and then they're not going
back to the classroom
and so the teachers unions are screwing
these kids man there's i just
can't um i can't find the data the
science that supports keeping these kids
by themselves
um even our kid has been back um
in a regular public school they got to
wear masks out of these things but
but man he gets to interact with their
kids and he gets to be around other kids
he's gotta gets to run around and these
they're they're making up new game but
there's with other people
um and i'm i'm hearing stories about
um reading stories about teachers unions
trying to say yeah
we'll let them back but why we're going
to replace the air conditioning
complexes or we've got to fill in the
blank and using these moments
to try to get other gains for the
teachers man my wife's a teacher i'm
from teachers i've been a teacher i'm
all about teachers but
it's all about these kids it is about
these kids at the end of the day that's
why we are teachers that's why i was a
teacher my wife's teacher
because we're about these kids and these
kids are dying on the vine dave it's
really it's it every mental health
professional i know
is predicting a just a collapse of these
kids when they go back
um because they've just been separate
for so long and it's just a mess you
know
one of the things we've talked about and
the data is there it's been there for
years i remember reading it a long time
ago and then you reminded me of it the
other day
that um teens need
physical proximity to
figure out who they are right and they
even
the thing it's if you've never heard
this before it's going to sound strange
to you but
you're even their heartbeats start to
they they regulate officers
yeah their eyes they hit each other
they're the uh uh
you know they they not only pick up the
same words and vernacular and those
kinds of things but
literally the physiology of their bodies
is into it has to be with other tend to
connect yes and when you don't have that
it's not developing properly
it's that's exactly right and you you
don't get that
that teacher that just puts that hand on
the shoulder
that just winks at the kid in the
hallway we used to call it accidental
community
where you as a teacher you just watch
for that one kid who's got his heads
down
who's not getting it at home who's not
getting it who's getting beat up by his
older brother who's struggling on the
bus whatever the thing is
and it's those little touch points that
a teacher can provide that that school
counselor that school principal that
coach can
not the academics no it's the relational
quality yes
yeah yeah you can get socialization we
can transfer information that's that's
the easy part
it's talking to the teacher that's
that's showing you
man you should see my son coming home
from history he is learning the
narrative these stories
and they've come alive and he's asking
questions at home that i never dreamed a
10 year old
that's because he's got a relationship
with somebody that he trusts
who's given him this information right
and and he could read a book
it would go in one ear and out the other
but this teacher is helping to come
alive in him right and so all it to say
is man
where you can find ways to let your kids
be around other kids find ways to
connect with your kids
find ways to get them out with other
children this is
far more dangerous than the virus
i think it is that's the statement i
made yeah i i can't see a way that it's
not dave
um i i have not seen been compelled by
the data on kids
yeah i mean the first time i heard you
um talk was uh
uh
you talked about screens before covid
before covington i mean i don't know
three four years ago i heard you do a
talk
and you were talking about the damage uh
not necessarily from the bullying the
bullying's part of it but not
necessarily from that but the damage
that this lack of physical proximity
to create socialization and proper
development
in a child 7 to 18
7 to 27 years old think of it this way
we
you know depending on what stats you
read it's 70 to 90 of communication is
nonverbal
right and so when you export all of your
interaction with somebody to
zeros and ones to text messages you're
you're communicating 20 30
you're missing shoulder movement and
body posture and eye crinkles
and this syncing up that we do together
right so yeah i have not seen any data
that said kids don't need to be back in
schools that kova is just wiping out
kids in fact it's been the opposite it's
taken out folks who are
older who are um not in good health
right who
have other things going on now of course
there's the outliers we hear about
are you seeing the mental health
community starting to raise this banner
i've they've been doing it for a year
all along i've been all along
they weren't getting a platform you
can't there's no platform and everyone
is so busy
throwing things up online just so they
could see folks right
because they knew this crisis was going
to emerge and this the other thing think
about
um if you had someone that you love your
grandparent died in a car wreck
the last thing you're going to do is go
watch anything that has to do with car
wrecks until you're until you heal
and if your grandparent passed away from
covet or you have someone you love
passed away from covet
every news story every everything's
about covent cove cove so these kids are
just
looping on this all day long all day
long all day long
and those loops just become that anxiety
when you can't take that anxiety anymore
that's when that that weight just takes
over you that's when you just sit back
and you fade back and we call that
depression that's what you just unplug
from
from the world man and we're just what
we're just watching it happen with kid
after kid after kid after kid
and at some point whether you got to run
around and play outside
i don't care how you have to do it you
got to get your kids in proximity of
their kids
you have to dave even when it comes to
church the bible says don't forsake the
gathering of the believers figure it out
i've heard of churches meeting in
people's backyard whatever you got to do
you need to be in proximity
figurative human beings right human
beings need relationship
to function properly got to it is not
good
that man be alone and uh
this is what we're seeing and we're
seeing this in careers we're seeing it
in businesses
uh we're seeing it with this article uh
what was this article out of
psychology today psychology today on the
loneliness and depression and suicide
rate of teens
yeah it's really tough man um and
even this let's say you're in a city in
a town where you just can't or you live
in a
highly compressed city
that means you're gonna have to go over
the top being engaged with your kid
yeah you're gonna have to put your
electronics away moms and dads and
you're gonna have to plug in you're
gonna have to figure out how to kick a
soccer ball in your living room you have
to do this
first 30 days binge watching netflix was
okay it's over
it's not okay now it's not okay anymore
these screens are killing
find ways to engage with your kids